Let's think about the binary
search algorithm.
We're given a sorted array, A,
containing let's say n unique elements.
Then, given a target value, v,
you want to find the largest index
i such that a sub i is at most v.
You can find this index
by binary search.
To compute the number of cache misses,
you'd set up recurrence, like so.
Once the search interval
falls within a cache line,
there would be just one cache miss.
Otherwise, you'd pay for one miss,
plus any additional misses to search
the remaining half of the array.
Solving the recurrence,
you'd find the following.
Big O of log n over l.
Compare this to the lower bound.
Binary search differs from the lower
bound by about a factor of log L.
So it's not optimal, but
one nice thing about binary search is
that it's already cache oblivious.
It makes no references to the cache
size Z or the line size L.
But it begs the question,
how do we get to the lower bound?
In fact, there's a way to do it.
Leave the logic of the binary
search algorithm intact, but
change the data layout.
Remember that a binary search tree
maintains some ordering of its elements.
Let's number this tree according
to an in-order traversal.
If you interpret these numbers
as addresses or index positions,
then the layout of the tree nodes
is equivalent to sorted order.
But there's nothing
sacred about this layout.
In fact let's consider
a different ordering which is
called the Vanamdebos layout.
I’ll sketch this now but
if you want some details,
see the nice tutorial by Erik Demaine.
The idea is to use
the following recursive layout.
Suppose you start with
a complete binary search tree.
If it has about n nodes it
should have log n levels.
Now divide the levels in half.
So there would be about one half
log n levels above the cut line and
about one half log n below.
This also means the upper subtree
will have about root n nodes.
Below the cut line, there will about
root n subtrees, each of size root n.
Here's the Van Emde Boas layout idea.
You have a binary search tree that you'd
like to lay out linearly in slow memory.
After partitioning the levels,
lay out all of the upper
sub-tree elements together.
And then concatenate them with
the lower sub-tree elements.
And when I say lay out
the elements together,
I mean recursively apply the Van
Emde Boas layout to each sub-tree.
So, what does this buy you?
Let's zoom in on the tree,
looking at the point where
the sub-trees fit within cache lines.
That is, in the figure the elements in
each of the smallest sub trees shown
fit within a cache line size hole.
A binary search in this tree takes
some path from the root to the leaf.
Since the sub trees are a size L,
you only generate a cache miss when you
hit the root of one of the sub trees.
Now the maximum height of one of these
little cache line size sub trees is
log L.
So, starting at the root of the tree,
how many of these size L
sub trees will you visit?
Well, the height of the tree is log-n.
So, on any path from root to leaf,
you'll encounter log-n
over log-l sub-trees.
That's totally awesome
because that is optimal.
Woot!
The important lesson is
that data layout matters.
What we did hear that was so
cool is we took the standard binary
search algorithm, reshuffled how we
stored the data in order to get an IO
optimal algorithm, and
the layout is itself cache-oblivious.